اعلن الحرس الثوري الايراني مقتل احد
مستشاريه القدامى في سوريا خلال غاره
اسرائيليه صاروخيه في منطقه السيده زينب
بريف دمشق وقال الحرس الثوري في بيان له
ان المستشار رضا موسوي يحمل رتبه لواء
وانه كان مسؤول وحده دعم المقاومه في
سوريا وحذر الحرس الثوري من ان اسرائيل
سوف تدفع ثمن جريمه الاغتيال حسب تعبيره
وقالت وكاله انباء التسنيم الايرانيه ان
رضا موسوي كان مقربا من قاسم سليماني
القائد السابق لفيلق القدس في الحرس
الثوري الايراني كما تواعد الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي بدفع اسرائيل
الثمن على اغتيال رضا
موسوي ينضم الينا من طهران مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد القادر فايز عبد القادر ما هي
التداعيات بعد مقتل رجل
وازن في
ايران جمال يمكن ان نقول بان المعلومات
الخاصه التي حصلنا عليها هنا تشير الى ان
ما جرى هو عمليه اختيال مخطط لها بحسب
المصادر هنا في طهران من قبل اسرائيل بشكل
واضح وبان رضا او رضي
موسوي كان مستهدفا من قبل اسرائيل بشكل
دائم وبانه تعرض الى محاولتي اغتيال
سابقتين من قبل اسرائيل على الاراضي
السوريه ولكن كانت محاولات فاشله وبان هذه
المحاوله هي المحاوله الثالثه التي نجحت
اسرائيل في الوصول الى الرجل وقتله في
سوريا كذلك في المعلومات هناك ايضا بان
اسرائيل قصفت ثلاث مناطق بشكل متزامن
قريبه من بعضها البعض بصواريخ
موجهه لكي تضمن ربما الوصول الصول الى
الرجل بشكل كامل وهذا جرى في محيط العاصمه
دمشق وتحديدا في حي السيده زينب المعروف
ربما بتواجد لهذه القيادات من هذا النوع
وبانه ذو كثافه سكانيه عاليه بالمناسبه
هذا الحي في محيط العاصمه السوريه كذلك في
المعلومات
بانه قتل لوحده بان ان ولم يتم قتل اشخاص
اخرين بمعنى ان الرجل استهدف في مكان
مباشر ب صواريخ موجهه من قبل اسرائيل
وبشكل متعمد بحسب المصادر هنا لذلك ايران
الرسميه الحرس الثوري الرئيس
الايراني الجمهوريه الاسلاميه تتعامل مع
هذا الموضوع على انه اختيال من قبل
اسرائيل وطبع ه سيكون هنا رد حقيقه ل
الحرس الثوري في سوريا هل سيكون هناك رد
عبد
القادر بطبيعه الحال بيان الحرس تحدث على
ان اسرائيل ستدفع الثمن الرئيس الايراني
كذلك تحدث على ان اسرائيل ستدفع الثمن
الاعلام الايراني يفتح تغطيه مفتوحه ح
حقيقه
لتغطيه ما قام به هذا الرجل وهو جنرال
التنسيق او الاسناد في سوريا
وهناك من يقول بانه مرتبط بشكل مباشر
بجبهه جنوب لبنان المشتعله الان في في
الحرب مع اسرائيل وكذلك مرتبط بتنسيق
وترتيب لوجستي على الاقل لجبهه المقاومه
فيما يخص ص الحرب الاسرائيليه في غزه لذلك
نحن نتحدث عن ساحات تتقاطع فيها ربما هذه
الاشياء هل سيرد الحرس الثوري بحسب البيان
الرسمي هذا ما يقوله ولكن كيف سيفعل ذلك
اين ومتى وكيف والاليات التي سيقوم بها
هذا بطبيعه الحال يمكن الحديث عنه على
الاقل في هذه المرحله ولكن نشير جمال الى
ان ايران كلما كانت تتعرض الى ضربه وازنه
من هذا النوع لم تكن تفضل ان يقوم حلفاؤها
في المنطقه بالرد على اسرائيل لان هناك من
يتحدث الان وبكثره ربما على ان الحزب حزب
الله في لبنان قد يكون معى معني بطبيعه
الرد ولكن الترجيح بان ايران ترجح وتفضل
ان تتحرك في مثل هذه المساحات كدوله اي ان
تقوم بالرد بيدها ولكن هل سيتم ذلك في
مناطق الظل والمناطق الرماديه دون الاعلان
ودون الاعتراف بما يجري ربما ام سيتم ذلك
بشكل معلن واضح صريح لذلك هذا متروك
بطبيعه الحال لتقديرات الحرس الثوري فيما
يجري في هذه المنطقه نعلم تماما جمال بان
ايران حتى الان في الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه
تدفع باتجاه وقف اطلاق النار في الحرب
الاسرائيليه لما يجري في غزه وقف اطلاق
نار شامل وكامل وادخال كامل للمساعدات
وهذا واضح سواء في التحرك العسكري لحلفاء
ايران في المنطقه او في التوجه السياسي
لايران كذلك هل ستبقى ايران ملتزمه بهذا
السقف الاستراتيجي تجي عدم توسيع الحرب
والضغط بربما عسكريا في مناطق مختلفه
وتفعيل جهود سياسيه ل الوصول الى وقف
اطلاق نار شامل في غزه ام انها ستتخذ قرار
اخر وسيكون للحرس راي اخر نتحدث عن شخص
وازن في سوريا جنرال مهم يحمل صفه ورتبه
لواء التقدير اخيرا جمال بان ربما ايران
لا بحسب المصادر هنا لا تريد ان تتحرك
بشكل العاطفي وبان الحرس الثوري يفكر
بمستويات مختلفه للرد شكرا لك عبد القادر
فايز مدير مكتب الجزيره في طهران في خبر
عاجل اي